Rishi sunak is always talking about
trade-offs and this was his great debate
with Liz Truss It would be so wonderful
to grow the economy we we must go for
growth policies and frankly we don't
have a lot of those right now but even
if the government were going hard on
growth policies they probably wouldn't
be coming into effect for a few years so
if you want to cut tax responsibly next
year in a way that doesn't upset the
markets again you're going to need to
finance them you're going to need to
find the money that's probably going to
come down to spending restraint so how
much they actually find is going to
probably equate to the tax cuts we get
and Rishi sunak is discovering as prime
minister it's really hard to get your
MPS to commit to Rolling back the size
of the state